[Music]  hey mom can we talk about dad so when  you guys got together was dad always an  evil okay well here it is  you've so many plans he was sweet Bishop  he said he wanted to conquer the world I  thought it was a figure of speech but if  I had never met Garmadon I would have  never had you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  dear students I I true ninja knows and  when to fight and when to the Lord  that's right it's void dad it's okay  Lloyd nobody's parents are perfect yeah  but I feel like there's more to Garmadon  that I need to know to understand your  future you must go back to your ninja  loose your dad  what's a ninja to the noise you hear  that we don't waken the unstoppable  beast  the Alfa are you ready to risk your life  for ninja ninja  I haven't felt that good in a long time  no Lloyd are you okay yeah yeah I think  I think what's my arm is it bad I want  to look a scale of 1 to 10 to help that  is it oh I'd say it's about a 7-point  arm ripped off  [Music]